you hear that that's the sound of all
Windows 10 users crying that they don't
have a great laptop
I know carpal tunnel came with this
laptop when I bought it the screen is
fine long as I don't touch it move my
head why are you it's running out of
battery I can't keep you charged but you
know what I don't blame them
Windows 10 is great so where is the
great Windows laptop that can stand
proudly next to it one that excels in
the four areas that I think are the most
important design keyboard and trackpad
performance and battery life I know it's
a tall order but hey my MacBook Air can
do it all even while running Windows 10
so in preparation for the coming school
year I went in search of its PC
counterpart testing 16 different
machines the best value for most people
comes between the eight hundred and
twelve hundred dollar range for that
price you get thin and light designs
high resolution screens and the latest
Intel Core i5 or i7 processors of all
the laptops I tested the Dell XPS 13
with the best it has a 13 inch
high-resolution screen crammed into a
very small frame a good keyboard and
it's plenty fast the trackpad still
isn't great and you need to get the
model with the lower resolution screen
to get the 9 hours of battery life in
the $600 to $800 category you'll make
some sacrifices but you still can get an
ok Intel processor an HD screen and good
build quality and design the asou sin
book ux305 cost $700 and is just 2.6
pounds it doesn't have a touchscreen but
it has a nice non-glossy 1080p display
the keyboard and trackpad are
surprisingly good and the battery lasts
about 6 hours on a charge if you want a
touchscreen then look at the $600 Dell
Inspiron 13 2 and 1 I tested five
laptops under 450 dollars
and while the specs are ok they're
really pain
to use the best one I found this $450
Toshiba radius 14 has a core i3
processor and it even flips around but
looking at the screen is like staring
into a faded mirror and it's hard to see
windows under all of Toshiba's
pre-loaded bloatware this Acer was even
worse seriously does keep that off if
you're in a rush to buy a laptop make
sure you can get one that you can live
with by spending at least $600 and
ideally between 800 and $1000 if you can
hold off things will likely get better
around the holiday season I'm expecting
a new Microsoft Surface and more laptops
that were made especially for Windows 10
Microsoft's great new software deserves
a piece of hardware that will put an end
to the tears once and for all